the US dollar dominates global trade in
2019 some 88% of international
transactions involved US dollars no
other currencies came close that gives
the u.s. extraordinary power over nearly
anyone who imports or exports anything
anywhere commodities like oil gold and
coffee are all priced in dollars
regardless of where they come from but
this cloud has long frustrated America's
rivals making them vulnerable to US
trade sanctions here's how the global
economy runs on the US dollar and why
some countries are developing
alternative systems that could chip away
at the dollars dominance the dollar came
to dominate trade after World War two
the US was the biggest economy in the
world other countries were trying to
rebuild and the dollar it was stable and
plentiful in 1944 a conference of 44
nations agreed to peg their currencies
to the US dollar while the dollar itself
was pegged to gold as global trade grew
so did the use of the dollar to conduct
the world's business even after the
United States abandoned the gold
standard in 1971 the dollar remained the
world's currency of choice the world has
gotten used to doing business in dollars
because it's just easier than doing
business in any other currency the
dollar is incredibly liquid meaning it's
easy to buy and sell things all over the
world the US banking system is very
efficient and those things combine to
make it cheaper for businesses to buy
and sell in dollars here's how a typical
international transaction works in u.s.
dollars a Canadian lumber company sells
boards to a French home builder the
buyers bank in France and the sellers
bank in Canada settled a payment in
dollars via correspondent banks in the
United States these correspondent banks
have accounts at the United States
Federal Reserve the money is transferred
seamlessly between these banks Fed
accounts because their status as
correspondent banks means they are seen
as safe counterparties the United States
says the use of these correspondent
banks means every transaction
technically touches US soil giving it
legal jurisdiction and compelling
foreign countries to abide by its laws
on money laundering
in corruption after 9/11 the u.s. used
the power of the dollar to advance its
foreign policy goals the idea was to cut
out the sources of funding for terror
organizations the u.s. used its control
of the dollar to increase surveillance
of global money flows and curb financing
toward bad actors it did this by
imposing sanctions on its rivals under
the system if a business or country
tries to trade with a sanctioned entity
in dollars the US has the power to cut
off its access to US currency but other
countries have been building workarounds
some EU countries oppose the US
sanctions against Iran
these sanctions put in place after the
u.s. withdrew from the Iranian nuclear
deal in 2018 included banning dollar
transactions with Iranian banks as a
result the EU is developing a euro back
system that is designed to facilitate
trade between Europe and Iran without
sending money across borders the EU
countries still in the Iran deal are
trying to figure out a way to work
around the u.s. system so they can trade
with Iran now that bothers the US which
is trying to exert maximum pressure on
the Iranian economy India already has an
alternative payment system in place that
it's using to do business with Iran
according to a Wall Street Journal
investigation it's been used to
facilitate transactions with sanctioned
Iranian entities but the United States
is still exerting its influence in the
Middle East through the power of the US
dollar the dollar still dominates global
trade you can see that in the standoff
between the u.s. and Iraq Iraq says they
want to throw us troops out of the
country the u.s. said we'll cut you off
from your dollars in the US system but
in the future it's not clear how strong
that threat will remain as other
countries chip away at the power of the
dollar if the power of the dollar falls
it could hurt the United States his
ability to control the global trading
system
you
[Music]